[Music]
oh my god it's still bleeding you know
I've had this done million times before
I never have taken this long for it to
stop I thought you never find that vein
these things are you given anyway hey
you're just a student nurse I'm sure but
you never get them where these before in
your life have you I don't think that's
right I don't think you should
experiment on me you know you you could
get somebody who doesn't count why don't
they get somebody competent to do this
kind of thing instead of using us as
guinea pigs you know well I'd really
rather talk to the doctor about this I
don't wanna spend my time talking to you
and then have to repeat it all over I
certainly hope I don't have to wait
around here for the doctor 30 or 40
minutes I wanted to come in and tell him
about this thing and and then get on
with it the ladies of the bridge club
just drive me crazy they well I when I'm
the dummy I have to sit there and wait
and I don't want to wait here now I
really hope he comes on in I want to
talk to him about this problem I'm
having
well how are you today it's real nice to
see you again on an informal basis I
have missed our informal chats and I
don't quite understand what interfered
with our getting together occasionally I
do try to share my feelings with you and
others who are working in the program
and I do like you but I've had some
moments of concern since my position has
changed as to how you are perceiving our
working relationship at this point I
understand that you have discussed this
with others and I questioned the
advisability of your doing this at this
particular time I feel like that both of
us have been with the program long
enough to understand some things and the
necessity for my involvement in
scheduling and activities so
although I like you very much I do
question what you do with your time
[Music]
warty yeah I've worried not worried now
I'm worried they just don't seem like
that I can get ahead on anything I'm
just I don't know it just just don't
seem like that that that I can make ends
meet I'm salary that I get and kids I've
got them on my mind and my wife it just
it's just something all-time I it just
it's disgusting enough I don't know why
I'll try
time and time again to to go get where I
could go and talk to teach her about kid
she keeps calling and saying that
they're always into something won't know
if I'm not going to do anything about it
and I don't know and I've got so much on
my mind I'm working two jobs I got my
mind on my wife now now then I've got my
kid I just don't know what to do it's
it's beyond me I know that there's I
just might as well stew give up because
the more I talk about the the worse I
get Doris I feel and I just just don't
seem that I can get anything over to
just seem like they know mark market I'm
talking about mine seem like they think
they just no no just a little bit more
than their parents do you know I'll just
with my financial situation and my
working status I just I've just gone my
lamington
nice to all kinds of thing
I liked
learning
and
and I enjoyed things
and
there was
there was a lot I was going to do
and now I can do any of it
now I don't understand why
I need to talk with you
it's hard for me to say this to you
because well it's hard to put into words
the way I feel but I just have to tell
you that I've been around here for a
long time and you are by far the finest
nursing student that I have ever seen on
this unit your confidence your
sensitivity your your understanding are
just what can I say they're their first
class I hope that when you graduate from
nursing school that you'll seriously
consider looking us up and coming to
work for us there's nobody else that
I've ever met that has your abilities
you're really great that's all I can say
will you look us up
I need to talk with you when people like
you come on the ward I make the
assumption that they are going to be of
some help to us in taking care of our
patients now I've seen people who are
students who make minor mistakes but
what you did falls out of the category
of a minor mistake and that starts
getting into where you can really do
some serious damage to another human
being now if you intend to stay on this
unit you will have to make certain make
certain that you do not ever make an
error like that again that's not just
incompetence
that's insensitivity and the kind of
insensitivity that you showed could have
killed a patient I don't ever want to
see that again on this unit and I don't
ever want to see your face if you ever
do anything like that again
you've been working here since I've been
coming to the doctor I went seeing you
before
you're nice
it's a good feeling sweetheart you wanna
try it sometime
you really should try it
maybe maybe after you get off work this
evening we could stop by this cute
little bar I know some real cute chicks
there I'm glad that's over with you know
you're really a really nice person I've
been coming to this place I forgotten
how long it's been now but I don't know
it seems didn't look to me like you and
I have a whole lot in common
uh I was wondering I was thinking about
this the other day I don't know what it
is but I really think you and I could
really make a go of it I've been here in
this office you know so uh why don't you
give me your phone number and maybe we
can set up a date sometime and and go
out and and I don't know
do whatever you want to do and I think
I've got a few friends that you might be
interested in - I've got several friends
they drop in my apartment all the time
and I don't know I think you and I could
really hit it off because I've already
noticed that we have a lot in common
I'm glad you stopped by
you know I've been here for a while now
and I've had a lot of time to think
about things well I've been thinking a
lot about you especially in the last
three or four nights you've been telling
me what what a great patient I've been
but I don't know if I've ever told you
what a fantastic person you are I think
what I'm trying to say is that I really
like you alive and you know I'd like to
be friends with you I mean close friends
yeah I'd maybe even like to get together
with you and you had some time we could
see each other when I get out of the
hospital I think we have a lot in common
how do you feel about that
you know you have problems I understand
that everyone has problems but you have
made an occupation out of having
problems we are not running a therapy
Institute here I cannot afford to deal
with you and your personal problems
constantly on an hour-by-hour basis nor
can the people that you work with you're
not a child anymore
this is not the type of organization
that we have here somewhere down the
line you're going to have to make a
commitment to being able to work out
things yourself on your own we cannot
afford to deal with this type of
material day after day week after week
do you have any idea how other people
relate to you here do you have any idea
how you're coming across to everyone
hey Florence Nightingale c'mere